For someone in the comedy space, I take things way too seriously
Mostly, games with my friends
Other times it comes from a place of caring
Like I'm hyperaware of everyone's feelings
And I feel this intense responsibility to make sure no one feels left out
Dude I love the one wheel. It feels like I'm flying
Right? All that terrain all the time!
I haven't quite figured out the dismount yet, but I'm getting there
We have to go to Santa Monica to ride at low tide. It is fantastic
Yesss
Wow... One wheels huh?
That sounds like too much fun
The two of you have one wheels?
I only have two wheels
You have two one wheels?!
No I have two wheels in one
Oh you mean like a bicycle?
A motorcycle
Oh! I mean - that's cool though
Cus it's like... If you have one that breaks, you have another
Yeah and you had to take a test for your two wheels whereas, we just bought our one wheels
Yeah but the two of you are having so much fun with one wheel
Oh my god D:
Thank you
One day I'll have one wheel
Today I just have two
Sometimes it's really stupid
Like I care about winning so much
More than any one person should
I am down to go above and beyond just for the knowledge that I won.
*cringe*
You're gonna throw up
Throwing up
But taking things seriously is part of the reason why I'm here
I mean this shot looks kinda nice right?
Look how much effort it took
I take comedy seriously
NO! The punch line has to end with the word banana or the whole thing falls apart!
I take my friends seriously
Why didn't you attend movie night last Thursday?
You clicked attending on the Facebook event but you didn't attend.
Anna
I'm sorry ;-;
Like you know how things are - it's Facebook
I'll make the next one
You didn't even post on the event wall
I'll die over a Facebook thing
You didn't even text me
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY EXTRA SNACKS I HAD?!
CAUSE TWO PEOPLE I THOUGHT WERE GONNA ATTEND DIDN'T SHOW UP
I even take masturbating seriously
Seriously, I have tried so many dildos; I've done so much research
Hehehe just kidding
What? Do you think I'm actually gonna do a masturbation cutaway?
Tch get the fuck out of here
*phone vibrates*
Seriously get the fuck out of here I have to stay on schedule
I've had people telling me to stop taking life so seriously
And I know what they mean
They mean don't stress yourself out over things that don't matter
But the problem is, only you can decide what matters
If Nerf games and role playing is something I'm passionate about, of course I'm going to treat it differently
And we all have those things, right?
Like I have a friend who's very intense about knitting
Or someone who's obsessed with metal music
I also have a friend who like loves and collects rocks so hard
And I think that this is a great thing
I think everyone's passions should be encouraged
Because think about it. If we didn't, then nothing would ever improve.
Someone had to care about the Nerf darts so much that they created the Accustrike dart
Which has better range and doesn't wobble as much as the other one because of it's rubber tip no matter what Wren and Jake say
So no matter what you take seriously, keep it up
You know? Don't be worried that it makes you weird
Because it's also what makes you, you
I'm Anna Akana, stay awsome Gotham
Thank you so much for Wren and Jake for being on the episode today
Wren and Jake are from the Sam and Niko and the Corridor Digital channel
I've put a playlist together of a lot of my favorite videos of theirs
You can watch right here
And it includes a video of me in this ridiculous mushroom hat
So feel free to check it out